en retraçant le voyage présidentiel en
val de loire de mai 1959
les archives départementales du
loir-et-cher illustre la façon de
gouverner du premier président de la
cinquième république
les services de l'elysée mobilise élus
chefs d'entreprise et professeurs pour
que la foule soit présente sur le
passage du cortège présidentiel
le maire d'onzain ici indique que la
population comme demander ce masque rade
sur le bord de la nationale ça se
traduit après sur les sur les
photographies on voit très bien que la
foule a répondu présente de façon
massive
il va au contact il est considéré
pratiquement comme l'inventeur de ceux
de cette méthode du bain de foule
ce que c'est un réel bain de foule et on
le voit sur les sur les photographies il
est immergé au sein des françaises et
des français
à chaque ville étape il y a un discours
très politique qui s'adresse à tous les
français
le discours est vraiment l'élément
central de l'étape du général il y en a
un qui est prévu dans chaque préfecture
à chaque ville préfecture un grand
discours est prononcé à orléans sur la
place du martroi
au château de blois dans la cour devant
la halle gaston d'orléans
donc c'est vraiment le moment qui est
attendu par la population c'est là
qu'elle se massent on a des images de la
place jean jaurès à tours qui est
absolument noire de monde donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est attendu
le discours de charles de gaulle
président est très particulier très
particulier sur l'addiction sur les
intonations il fait des pauses
il insiste sur certains mots et je pense
que cette façon d'incarner aussi les
discours et être
une façon pour lui de faire répondre
aussi la population qu'elle manifeste
encore une fois son adhésion à sa vision
avec des pauses des applaudissements
chaque discours se conclut par la
marseillaise ont vraiment un moment de
d'union nationale beaucoup d'articles de
presse de photos et de films
d'actualités ont été retrouvées pour
cette exposition
ce déplacement en province est suivi par
pas moins de vingt-cinq journalistes
accrédités les actualités françaises
suivent très largement le général ils
vont tourner presque une demi-heure de
l'image sur sur les différentes étapes
du trajet et puis on va faire en sorte
que
le discours du général puisse être
diffusée de la façon la plus rapide
possible donc les discours sont
transcrits par des sténodactylo qui vont
faire vérifier ensuite bien sûr aux
autorités la transcription du discours
et on transmet immédiatement la presse
qui peut communiquer via des lignes
téléphoniques spécialement installé pour
la journée aux rédactions parisiennes si
dès le lendemain on trouvera dans la
presse les grandes lignes du discours du
général l'an province le président
charles de gaulle est le premier à
utiliser tous ses moyens de
communication modernes pour mettre en
valeur ses idées phare sa vision
politique et le rôle des journalistes
qu'ils s'agissent des journalistes de la
presse écrite ou deux de la télévision
avec les actualités la diffusion d
actualité ça va être de montrer dans la
france entière qu'à chaque étape
même dans chaque commune la plus reculés
du territoire et bien la foule et
présente les françaises et les français
soutiennent leur nouveau président et sa
et sa vision politique président de la
fondation charles de gaulle est présent
au rendez vous d'histoire
hervé gaymard retrouve dans cette
exposition la marque de fabrique du
gaullisme
gouverner c'est un carnet
c'est absolument évident et lui il
incarnait la france mais c'était pas une
france détaché de la population comme on
a pu le penser parce qu'au contraire ils
voulaient rencontrer les français et il
le faisait à l'occasion de ses
déplacements
une exposition qui démontre que soixante
ans après les méthodes pour gouverner la
vème république n'ont pas beaucoup
changé